plasma is the fourth state of matter
it's what happens when you heat Beyond a
gas you ionize you break apart the atom
into its constituent nucleus and its
electronic content the nucleus is
positively charged it's made of protons
and neutrons and the electrons are just
separate uh individualistic particles
there's another type of particle which
is very important but we won't get into
called the neutrino and that that's
actually the only form of dark matter
that we know for sure exists so you've
heard about dark matter we've never
observed any other dark matter in the
universe besides a neutrino but they're
not relevant necessarily for either life
or what we have right you have this
plasma of protons electrons that aren't
associating with one another now that's
a relatively uniform field of protons
and electrons it's super hot now it's
only relatively uniform it starts to
Clump together and the reason it clumps
together is because of gravitational
attraction right clumps together in
material I believe it's because of
quantum uncertainty it isn't a hundred
percent uniform some of these primordial
particles are a little bit closer to
others than others are there's a there's
a slight non-uniformity about it and now
and now you get clumping the bigger the
clump that emerges the more likely it is
to accrete additional matter and then
that keeps happening until you get the
beginning of clumps of matter that are
large enough to be stars and then the
stars have enough gravitational force to
produce additional nuclear Trends or
Atomic Transformations and the Stars
start to generate the rest of the
periodic table of the elements
foreign
[Music]